foreign
fight
oh
[Music]
[Music]
do this
hmm
yes
it's official tekken 8 is coming to the
playstation 5 console courtesy of our
battle-hardened friends at bandai namco
entertainment
now let's check in on two games in
development for playstation vr2
[Music]
the story i was telling it was about a
certain droid repair tech who had no
business getting into this kind of
trouble
but there they were standing against
evil wherever it popped up
i think there are a few new items on the
shelves that might catch your eye
the locals can be a little rough on
tourists but uh it's nothing you can't
handle
the first order on battle surely we can
count on you now
oh
hello my friend
ready for battle
let all monsters beware
my aim is true
taste my seal
i call
[Music]
you will be destroyed
by sovereignty
[Music]
d neo brings the creativity and chaos of
a tabletop rpg to psvr2
this next game is being rebuilt from the
ground up and will be available outside
of japan for the first time
foreign
foreign
you
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hello madame mason i understand you have
a shop to sell
i think you will find my terms quite
generous
what's the catch
you are wise to be wary
why is your mistress selling the shop
she has had rotten bad luck with the
last few tenants
those who came before you just could not
seem to escape the darkness
will you
watch your step
hahaha
[Music]
you are within the bounds of the olympic
exclusion zone if you can hear this
message you are trespassing on
government property evacuate immediately
alert alert you are within the olympic
exclusion zone
[Music]
so
[Music]
uh
warning warning an instability front is
approaching take immediate shelter in a
stabilized area
locations impacted include sectors
so
[Laughter]
another one
after all these years
call her now
[Music]
survive a ride from hell in pacific
drive the debut game from ironwood
studio
up next let's check in on playstation
stars a loyalty program rolling out soon
hi everyone i'm grace chen
not long ago we announced our brand new
loyalty program called playstation stars
it's designed to celebrate you the
players it will be free to join
playstation stars as a member you can
complete various activities to earn
points that can be redeemed for rewards
digital collectibles are a highlight of
the program these are digital
representations of things that
playstation fans love today i'm pleased
to give you a sneak peek at some
examples of our digital collectibles
whether it's a beloved game character or
a cherished device from sony's
innovative history there will always be
something new to collect and show off to
your friends
[Music]
and i have more good news playstation
stars will begin to roll out in some
regions in asia starting in late
september it will launch in the americas
and europe in the weeks that follow
that's it for now check playstation blog
to learn more about playstation stars
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
these next two intense action games are
ps5 console exclusives let's take a look
[Music]
at
[Music]
[Music]
is
honey
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
um yes
[Music]
[Music]
after three centuries of the tokugawa's
repressive rule
the black ships appeared without warning
and our nation began to tear itself
apart those who cleave to the past
those who embrace the new
and the ronin
a warrior free of all masters and bonds
[Music]
i will watch over you all
as your blades carve a new future
your time has come
rise
as one
experience an era of great change and
upheaval in rise of the ronin a
sprawling action rpg from team ninja
before we wrap up we've got one more
update for you
[Music]
everyone keeps secrets
sometimes it's the only way to protect
the ones we love
[Music]
i know you
god killer
what is it you want from me
is it a god of war you came to find
[Music]
you don't really want war
do your kratos
all that blood on your hands
on your son's hands
what is it you will not tell me i can't
talk about it
but i just need you to trust me
we follow your every whim but you don't
believe in any of it and still i follow
because all that matters is that you are
safe but that's not all that matters
who's keeping you safe
i do not need you to protect me
sure about that
pretender god
for the old father death can happen
what do you even know of god's help
in your lifetimes has anyone ever
worshipped you
ever prayed to you
can you even imagine that kind of love
no
you don't care about anything beyond
yourself
beyond the monster who kills without
cause
[Music]
fate only binds you if you let it
do what's necessary
not because it is written
[Music]
we will make our own destiny
[Music]
and that's the show god of war ragnarok
comes to ps5 at ps4 on november 9th see
you next time